a conservative who sees someone crossing
the border illegally will say look
you're a criminal you've violated the
laws of this country and I think quite a
few liberals at this point they're
uneasy with that you know what right do
we have to if the laws are unjust and
maybe it's just unjust to tell all these
people they're not allowed to enter the
country whether there is such a thing as
as a nation whether it exists in history
whether people belonging to one nation
actually should treat one another in a
different way from the way that they
treat people from other nations this is
this is the heart of politics today